on the impeachment
looking back because you're part of it
you get the experience that do you think
they strengthened or weakened this
nation
I think it weakened in many respects
just the way that it was conducted I
mean there's a new book coming out by a
couple of journalists in the Washington
Post I haven't actually seen it yet but
I really did you know kind of worry that
myself that it became a spectacle
and although it actually I think in many
respects was important in terms of an
exercise of civic responsibility and you
know give people a big massive lesson in
Civics everyone's kind of running out
and looking up the whole process of
impeachment and what that meant and
Congressional prerogatives I was as well
I was you know like running off myself
and you know trying to learn an enormous
amount about it because I was in the
middle of all of this
that it didn't ultimately show
responsibility and accountability
and that in itself was kind of was
weakened because
on on you know both sides there was a
lot of parties on politics
uh I mean I think that there was a
dereliction of Duty uh in many respects
I mean especially I have to say on the
part of Republican members of Congress
um who were you know kind of they should
have been embarrassing you know
congress's prerogatives you could have
you know kind of basically done this in
a in something of a different way but
the whole thing is because it was this
larger atmosphere of polarized I don't
know polarized but fractured fractured
politics and I was deeply disappointed I
have to say and many of the members of
Congress on uh the Republican side I
mean there's a lot of grandstanding that
I really didn't like one bit on the
Democratic side either and and not
admitting to mistakes and you know not
kind of addressing head-on you know the
fact that they'd you know kind of been
pushing for you know Trump to be
impeached and you know talking about
them and being an illegitimate president
you know kind of right from the the very
beginning and that you know as a result
a lot of people just saw this this is
kind of a continuation of you know
political games you know coming out of
the 2016 election but on the Republican
side it was just a game there was people
I knew who were you know basically you
know one point one of them winked at me
you know in the middle of this you know
kind of impeachment it's just like don't
take this personally you know this is
there's the game this is a game and I
just thought this isn't a game and
that's why I think that it you know kind
of weakened because I mean again on the
outside it it weakened us the whole
process weakened Us in the eyes of the
world because again the United States
was the gold standard and I do think I
mean again in the in the terms of the
larger population although a lot of
people did actually see the system you
know standing up trying to do something
to hold people account but there still
was that element of circus and a big
political game and people being careless
with the country but I do think that the
Democrats
were the instigators of the circus so as
a
it's perhaps subtle but there's a
there's a different way you talk about
issues or concerns about accountability
when you care about your country when
you love your country when you love the
ideals and when you uh versus when you
just want to win and stick it to the
other side I agree I mean there were
people who um I actually thought managed
that that made it about the country
rather than about themselves
yeah there were a lot of those who did a
lot of grandstanding yeah and that's
that's another problem of our political
incentive structures the the kind of
sense of accountability and
responsibility tends to be personal you
know people whether people decide to do
it or not it's not institutional if that
makes sense we've added kind of a
breakdown of that kind of that sense now
I took an oath of office and I'm
assuming that most of them did too you
know I had to be sworn in you know when
I I took those positions I took that
seriously but I already took an oath of
citizenship there's you know presumably
you did too you know you kind of started
to become an American citizen it's not
something you take on lightly
and you know that's why I felt this deep
sense of responsibility all the time
which is why I went into the
administration in the first place I mean
I got a lot of flack for it because you
know I thought well look I've been asked
and there's a real issue here after the
Russian interference and you know the
whole influence operation in the 2016
elections and I knew what was going on
and I should do something
you know if not me then you know okay
someone else will go and do it but can I
live with myself just sitting on the
sidelines and criticizing what people
are doing you know and kind of you know
worrying about this or am I actually
going to muck in there and you know just
go and do something it's like seeing
your house on fire and you see that you
know okay this is pretty awful and
dangerous but I could go in there and
and do something